the firm says the plan built in
partnership with chinese
manufacturer envision will eventually
create
6 200 jobs the 1 billion pound hub
which could be operational by 2024 could
become the largest battery factory
in the whole of the uk it's expected to
have capacity
for nine gigawatt hours per year
sufficient to produce batteries for up
to
one hundred thousand vehicles every
single year
earlier i asked the business secretary
quasi quatting whether nissan had been
given taxpayers money
to help build the factory i wouldn't say
that they're pushing at an
open door we always look to get a good
investment in terms of taxpayers money
but they have a
very good relationship with us they've
been here since 1986
and they want to commit to this plant
for decades to come okay why electric
cars over synthetic fuel
i think electric cars have proven
their green credentials uh they're
popular people are
buying them in increasing numbers and
it's really the way of the future and
that's why nissan are investing
so heavily here in the northeast and
that's why that many
countries competitive advanced economies
are seeking to attract this kind of
investment
to build gigafactories uh so that they
can build
electric vehicles these are the the
transport of the future
tamara is here hi tomorrow so is nissan
receiving government money to do this
well quasi-quartering was a bit
tight-lipped about that obviously great
news for sunderland biggest investment
since nissan arrived we believe in the
1980s it's going to create 1600 jobs
in the factory and thousands more as you
were saying in in the supply chain to
create batteries for tens of thousands
of electric cars when it gets
up and running the question is of course
of the billion pound investment how much
did the government
put in because that's the question that
other companies are going to be asking
as we go forward
whether that investment is going to be
available to all
uh the reason quasi quatering says it's
the it's the technology of the future is
because
petrol and diesel cars are going to be
banned new sales are going to be banned
from 2030.
so he says the future is electric but a
lot to be done in terms of scaling up
the the infrastructure for that and of
course bringing down the price